today we're going to be speaking with
frank von hippel who is a professor at
northern arizona university and author
of the book the chemical age how
chemists fought famine and disease
killed millions and changed our
relationship with the earth
and frank you know in in reading about
the history of
chemistry and and chemists it seems that
a theme
with with essentially every
technological advancement in human
history
agriculture comes to mind nuclear power
comes to mind
we both have much good and the
possibility of
of much bad that am i am i correctly
understanding that that is essentially
the broad history of chemistry yes for
sure and and like you're saying it's
also the history with physics and many
other fields that lead to technological
advances that we have these wonderful
innovations
but they have massive unintended
consequences
i think a lot of times when people think
about chemistry
they think about the last 100 years 150
years maybe 200 years
and they think of chemicals that include
things like
pesticides as an example or chemistry
used in in medical technologies but the
history of chemistry really goes back
much further than that it does it really
goes back to alchemy in a way where
people were using trial and error to
find
new ways of doing things often
impossible things like trying to turn
lead into gold but
those experiments led to a lot of
advancements and i would say that
modern chemistry really arose in the
early 1800s with the advent of organic
chemistry
as chemists learned how to synthesize
different kinds of chemicals that are
only otherwise found in nature and
that's what gave rise to our modern
pesticides are modern chemical weapons
and so on
it seems that correct me if i'm wrong
but there's a bit of an analogous
history
with um what what we now know of as
two very different fields astronomy and
astrology
at one point there were there was an
overlap between those and then they
eventually sort of separated it and much
the same way
alchemy which now is the subject of many
sort of pseudoscience books and and
sometimes overlaps with everything from
psychics and other things
at one point it was right there at the
start of modern chemistry as well
that's exactly right and so with the
advent of modern science where we
disprove things and we
subject ideas to experimentation of
course alchemy went away
and we have the the modern field of
chemistry rise out of that
when we start to think back in the
history of chemistry
and thinking about the the major
breakthroughs within the field
what are sort of like the top level most
important
milestones well i would say the first
one would be the synthesis of urea by
frederick voller in 1828 and that's
really the
the point of origin of organic chemistry
but there are many others after that and
in terms of the
history of pesticides we have the first
commercial pesticide which was called
bordeaux mixture it was a copper sulfate
solution
in the 1870s and that then led to the
proliferation
of initially toxic metal based
pesticides
and then we had major inflection points
in world war one and world war
ii world war one because it was
incredible
cross fertilization of talent of
chemists who were working both on
pesticides and chemical weapons so we
had pesticides
become chemical weapons and we had
chemical weapons become pesticides
and by the end of world war one a
quarter of the artillery shells flying
over the trenches had chemical weapons
in them
which is extraordinary to think about
now just that was really a chemical war
it was the chemist who
who really decided the outcome of that
war and then things got
even more uh advanced and and
horrific in a way with world war ii
where we got the advent
of the organophosphate nerve gases like
sarin and tavin
which were developed by nazi scientists
and those developed into the modern
organophosphate
insecticides after the war so early on
in the history of pesticides i mean
my reading of it seems to suggest
that this was really seen as just a boon
and a great thing
uh the the all positives in the prose
column and really nothing in the cons
uh because it allowed more food to get
to the point at which it could provide
sustenance to people and it provided an
expansion of available calories and
really solved a lot of problems that
were that were prevalent at the time
was it that were there people sounding
alarms early on
and sort of like what is the history of
when the other side of pesticides
started to become more known
yeah it's a terrific question because
initially chemists who were developing
these chemicals were
fighting scourges of humanity that have
faced us since we
started agriculture they were fighting
famine and they were fighting
infectious diseases so famine because
crops are destroyed by pests like
rats and and cockroaches and and
uh grasshoppers and so on but also crops
are destroyed by plant pathogens and
that's what
led to the potato blight uh disaster
that caused the greatest
famine ever recorded in ireland in the
1840s so
chemists were trying to fight famine and
they're also trying to fight
infectious diseases that were vectored
by animals like malaria and yellow fever
typhus bubonic plague and so on and
so the motivations were really good and
these chemicals were quite effective
they were averting famine and averting
diseases
but the first alarms really started i
would say
right after world war one there were a
lot of people getting poisoned by
toxic metals in their food especially
lead
and arsenic which were used in
insecticides and often present on
produce and if
people didn't wash the produce they
could get poisoned from it
but even then it was kind of a grumbling
and then after world war ii there was
further grumbling as people saw
widespread loss of wildlife it really
wasn't until 1962 when rachel carson
published silent spring
that we saw massive public outrage about
the pollution
and the destruction of the environment
caused by these chemicals as well as
human health effects
when it comes to there's now sort of a
new sort of newer movement of
um earth-friendly and again it's this
idea of
of so-called pesticides but they're sort
of like non-chemical earth friendly
you know things i'm not actually i'm not
actually aware of what the substances
are but you'll sometimes hear hey you
know you can use uh
you spray lavender on your garden this
is not a real example but you put
lavender on your garden and then put
you know onion peels and then the
animals just don't come near
is is there does what does the the
chemistry community think about that
type of thing can
something totally innocuous really be as
effective as some of these
more uh pernicious chemical pesticides
or or is that
in order to get the huge benefit you've
got the huge risk as well
yeah so it's a great question and
unfortunately with the big benefit of
using chemical pesticides we also create
our own dependency on them because
these chemicals not only kill the pests
they kill
the predators and parasites of those
pests so they kill the spiders
that eat those pests they kill the um
the parasitoid wasps that infect those
pests they kill the birds that eat those
pests
and then you end up being in this
vicious cycle where you have to use more
and more chemicals to get the same yield
so it's not a simple answer and
and really there are many organic
solutions that don't require chemical
pesticides that are quite effective
but part of it has to do with the way
crops are rotated
growing a diversity of crops rather than
a monoculture if you have 10 000 acres
of the same
crop of course you're going to get an
outbreak of pests because
it's this giant salad bowl for them so
we need to be thinking holistically
about how we grow our food
and at the same time reserve chemicals
for when we really need them in my
opinion that would be
for fighting infectious diseases where
we we have outbreaks of pests that we
need to handle
yeah i i found uh absolutely fascinating
um
omnivores dilemma by by michael pollan
where he talks about going to joel
salatin's farm in i believe it's
virginia
and explains how there's this kind of
vicious cycle
of you know you start to need for
example
antibiotics for cows when the cows are
being fed grain
instead of grass because that's not
natural for the digestive system of the
cow
and it at least makes the case that at
some level
you can have this regenerative
agriculture that doesn't depend on
the types of pesticides that that you
write about in the book
can that can that really work at scale
yeah so i i think it's a great question
that we need to
explore as a society because it hasn't
really been tried
we went from operating to small farms
throughout the world to having
industrialized agriculture after world
war ii
population has grown tremendously and
now we need to see can we do it
sustainably we have to find a way to do
it sustainably because it's certainly
not sustainable
the way that we rely on chemicals now
and the damage it does to our health and
the environment
so there's going to be some kind of a
compromise where we're using the minimum
of these pesticides that that one needs
to use
while maximizing all of these other
benefits of using diverse agriculture
and
and and going to a smaller scale more
local markets why are we shipping foods
all around the world that can be grown
nearby
so we need to completely rethink our
agriculture
to go back a little bit to the uh sort
of public health side
of uh of of the field of chemistry
what do you make generally i mean i have
more specific questions but what do you
make generally
about the types of concerns expressed
over the last few months about the
coming coronavirus vaccines some based
on the speed with which the vaccines
were
developed some based more on conspiracy
theories about bill gates and microchips
but concerns that at least
some some seem in good faith about the
makeup of the vaccines
and the storage and the long-term effect
on the body
what's your general sense of the
discussion around vaccination right now
right so i'm a big advocate of vaccines
and including
the new vaccines coming out for code
that i think they're incredibly
important
and although the vaccine for cobit 19
was developed incredibly quickly over
the last 10 months or so
the technology it's based on has been in
development for 20 years
and so it's not it's it's a new
technology to be employed
for a human vaccine but it's been in
development for a long time
and the biology is well understood so to
me the vaccine looks very safe
it looks efficacious it's more
efficacious than many of us were
expecting
and certainly i'll be asking my parents
to get it as soon as it's available for
all the people and for the rest of us
when it's available
so i and as far as the these
um the slander against bill gates and
people like him it's just horrible here
you have someone who's
working very hard for the public benefit
using his own resources to do so
and then he's getting attacked for it i
just find it absolutely horrifying that
that's going on
one of the arguments that's sometimes
being made and to call it an argument
maybe is a bit of a stretch but one of
the claims that's being made
is that we don't know
if by test by testing these vaccines for
a few months on people in phase 3 trials
we don't know if a year two three four
years down the line there will be some
unforeseen follow-on effects now of
course it's a sort of indefeasible
argument in the sense that
if a vaccine's been around 50 years you
don't really know that after 51
it doesn't cause some new problems so
you could always make this argument but
in terms of what we know about vaccines
what the only thing i've been able to
find about
long-term vaccine effects that go beyond
a few days
is a vaccine the exact one i forget that
doubled the risk
of guillain-barre syndrome i think from
1 in 2 million
to 1 in 1 million over the life of the
individual
what can we say about generally speaking
at the chemical level the idea that
years down the line a vaccine could
cause something
sure and actually the example you gave
is a good one because typically where
vaccines have an adverse effect
it's at the scale of one in a million or
two in a million people that have some
serious consequence of that and if you
compare that to the
serious consequence of getting measles
or getting mumps or rubella or
or tetanus or any of these other things
that we get vaccinated
against it's it's there's no comparison
so yes there may be one in a million two
in a million people who do to their
genetic makeup and their environment
have some serious
consequence of a new vaccine but look at
the mortality rate
of people from covet 19 and we have
about one percent or almost one percent
of people infected are dying
and and that scale there's no comparison
to one in a million versus
one in a hundred so in terms of vaccine
history i think that's what the lesson
is is that
nearly always they prove to be safe
there are cases where they're not safe
you usually discover that quite quickly
and this happened with the dengue fever
vaccine for example
and so when those problems occur they're
pulled off the market the problem is
solved and
we're very lucky to live in a time where
the science is so advanced that
something like this can be developed
this quickly rather than
us suffering through 30 years of
covenant 19 before we have a solution
very very very well said we've been
speaking with frank von hippel who
teaches at northern arizona university
the book is the chemical age
how chemists fought famine and disease
killed millions and changed our
relationship with the earth
frank i so appreciate your time today
thank you so much david